you know despite the fact that people
are telling the libertarian sort of shut
up The Libertines were the only ones
willing to put their money on the line
and again keep this thing alive hi I'm
Nicolas Rio threes on TV joining me now
is New York Times reporter Nathaniel
popper is the author of the new book
digital gold Bitcoin in the inside story
of the misfits and millionaires trying
to reinvent money
it's a riveting narrative about how
Bitcoin went from being an idea sketched
on the nine page white paper that an
anonymous programmer was circulating
around during the summer of 2008 to a
global phenomenon that's captivated
Silicon Valley and what some people say
will be as transformative as the
Internet itself Daniel thanks for
joining thank you for having me give an
explanation of what bitcoin is and in a
couple of sentences for people who like
myself who at times have trouble kind of
conceptually grasp or yeah I mean look I
think that a lot of people even who have
spent a lot of time on this still have
trouble describing exactly what it is
and that's because it's actually a lot
of different things I think actually
probably the easiest place I find to
start is with this group of largely
privacy activists we're trying to create
digital cash they were trying to bring
the qualities of cash in the physical
world into the digital world because
when money moved on to the internet
suddenly you could track every movement
of each dollar each $20 and that scared
a lot of people particularly you know
privacy activists cypherpunks back in
the 90s and so this project I think Ferg
grew first out of this desire to create
digital cash something you could
transact with directly on the internet
without having to go through a middleman
right and making sure that the cash was
not just being made up by somebody's
exactly how do you write the difficulty
and why it took so long for this to be
invented is how do you create a digital
file that you can't be counterfeited
most digital files you can just copy and
paste them and the sort of genius of
Bitcoin from the beginning was here was
a kind of digital file this new kind of
money that couldn't be easily replicated
and counterfeit and then it's spread
around in a decentralized a totally
decentralized
whay right where people download a
program and everybody's computer acts as
a ledger for all of the transactions so
exactly at any point we know how much
Bitcoin is in circulation and that the
books always add up right everybody is
keeping track of everybody else and
keeping everybody else honest and and so
that's we might get to this later but
that's the other layer of Bitcoin which
is this ledger that everybody's keeping
and that can almost exist independent of
the currency the the bitcoins moving
around but that's that's important part
of what made this work so in the in the
book you profile all of these
fascinating characters who took
Satoshi's idea and ran with in it many
of them were radical libertarian to saw
potential in Bitcoin to put an end to a
kind of governmental control or monopoly
over cash over money talk about some of
these people and the role they played in
the early days of Bitcoin and why they
were so you know why they dropped this
technology so much it's fascinating to
look at bitcoins first two years really
because it was sort of constantly on the
edge of death of sort of disappearing
because there were so few people using
it you know at that point these bitcoins
were worth nothing and so it was just
sort of a fun project but the people who
got it through those first two years
were really largely sort of libertarian
or libertarian minded folks in the first
year this this finished college student
who'd gotten into libertarian ideas
reading on the internet and for about a
year he was almost the only person
working with Satoshi to keep this thing
alive
and as it grew more folks joined the
project with similar ideas and and look
I think at the simplest level a lot of
these folks have been made aware of the
monetary system and the potential
weaknesses it by the financial crisis
you know it raised this new awareness I
think outside the libertarian community
but particularly inside the libertarian
community about you know the way the
government creates money distributes
money and so there was I think this
widespread sense that you know let's
look for an alternative here let's
consider some other possibility I guess
within the
kind of manifesto or the white paper
that created Bitcoin and whatnot I mean
there are the ideas of kind of Milton
Friedman and of creating a fixed amount
of money with overall with a regular
increase of regular and predictable
increase that gets distributed through
an economy that's kind of baked into the
cake right and have the actual system
yeah those were the rules from the very
beginning that idea of scarcity but
controlled scarcity as you say unlike
gold which you know who knows when
they'll hit another vein of gold and and
you know raise the gold supply by a
quarter with Bitcoin you know exactly
how many are going to be created and
what is the death what is the end of of
new pit corn being a certainty if
everything goes according to plan will
be around twenty one forty then the last
bit of Bitcoin will be released into the
world and then you'll have 21 million
bitcoins with none none none to be
created again so that's when the real
intergalactic war will start okay so now
I mean your your book spends a lot of
time exploring the tensions between the
liberal libertarian Bitcoin boosters on
the one hand and another camp of early
Bitcoin champions who worried that
ideological posturing of exactly the
type that the libertarian boosters were
doing could hurt Bitcoin talk a little
bit about how that conflict you know
played out in the early days and what's
happening now yeah I mean look I think
that has been central and shaping
Bitcoin and shaping the public view of
Bitcoin because a lot of the early
libertarians were very outspoken about
the fact that this was something that
could you know replace governments had
had these radical possibilities very
utopian vision I think and then there
were the sort of programmers sometimes
privacy activists folks who weren't as
politically motivated but saw that there
was something really new in the computer
science here that this made some
possible that hadn't been possible
before and I think that group worried
that the politics were gonna scare away
potential mainstream acceptance and I
think you know one of the things that's
really interesting when you look at the
story is to see again just how important
you know
despite the fact that people were
telling the Libertarians to sort of shut
up the libertarians were the only ones
willing to put their money on the line
and again keep this thing alive at a
time when there wasn't much else to do
with it and there wasn't much other
reason to to own these and so what you
saw is these the people who are
ideologically motivated they cared
enough to put their money down and sort
of keep this going and and lead to the
sort of first price increases which then
raised public awareness
so you know it's always this
back-and-forth which you still have
today I think increasingly the sort of
politics of Bitcoin are getting pushed
to the side but it's important to
remember how important they were in
allowing Bitcoin to survive to this so
has you know have Silicon Valley
investors or the mainstream banking
industry have they effectively co-opted
Bitcoin or you know what's going on
there because I've certainly adopted it
yeah I mean the the last two years have
really been about big money coming in
and and it was first Silicon Valley and
there were a few real evangelists in
Silicon Valley who made this thing in
Silicon Valley that you know big and
venture capital firms wanted to invest
in more recently that spread to Wall
Street and and that to me is where a lot
of the most interesting work is going on
today firms like Goldman Sachs and JP
Morgan are dedicating real resources to
working on maybe not Bitcoin the
currency but the technology that
surrounds Bitcoin and the potential
there is that this is distributed you
know kind of information and accounting
things yeah I meant rid of
intermediaries right I I guess I think
of it you know Bitcoin we earlier talked
about the idea of sort of digital cash
in addition to that it's this sort of
global spreadsheet a shared spreadsheet
in the sky where you can keep track of
bitcoins and how bitcoins are moving but
you can also keep track of anything else
and so that's what all these new
startups that are thinking about how do
we use that ledger
you know in this this is the blockchain
technology talk a little bit about so
what does Goldman's I mean they're not
they're not investing in Bitcoin in the
sense of saying like oh you know what
we're gonna buy a bunch and then hope
the price goes up we're a short it
they're actually looking at blockchain
technology yeah how would they adapt
that to their business well I think
there are a lot of different ways but
essentially I think they view this as a
potential way to a new way to facilitate
any kind of transaction so that could
mean you know consumer payments that
could mean setting up a kind of network
to replace the visas and MX's of the
world I think the more near-term stuff
they're working on is using it as a
ledger for their own very large
transactions so you know a stock trade
today will take three days to settle and
in those three days in the current
system your money's tied up you don't
yet have the stock and the banks love
this idea that you have a ledger that
could allow for instant settlement and
clearing and potentially doing away with
some of those costly middlemen that you
know have always come up through Bitcoin
and there's I mean there's been a lot of
concern about a fudge factor right and
that whenever there's time between a
deal that's made and the settling and if
it's a couple days like lots of
weirdness can slip in yes and and it's
interesting you know so banks are
interested in that fact because they
don't want that risk and they don't want
to pay the cost that it currently that
they have to pay currently to go through
settle and clear stock trades but
interestingly central banks are also
very interested in this because they
worry about that risk they saw in the
2008 financial crisis where you had you
know Lehman Brothers going under and
there were all of these uncompleted
trades and what do you do with them so
that's why central bank's Bank of
England fed up fed here are also putting
real resources to researching this which
you know brings us to this amazing irony
that that the very institutions that
Bitcoin was designed to circumvent are
the institutions that are showing the
most interest in it the revolution turns
on itself but now a lot of people are a
lot of the conversation about Bitcoin in
the financial
our business press is really about
speculation on whether the price will go
up or down and whether it's real or fake
relatively few people use Bitcoin for
transactions but it's happening in
increasing numbers and it's happening in
Argentina of all places talk a little
bit about why Bitcoin seems to be
getting a purchase as a currency the
alternative in Argentina yeah to me this
was one of the most fascinating place I
went in the course of researching this
book because it was a place the Bitcoin
was actually kind of being used in in
the in keeping with the original spirit
of giving power to the people to hold
and control their own money so that they
don't have to rely on banks and central
banks and governments now especially in
Argentina has a centuries-old earth
century-old history at the very least of
kind of pumping up and and deflating its
currency or kind of screwing the people
who actually own own Argentine yeah I
mean Argentina is one of the most famous
cases you know sort of financial basket
cases they've had all these instances of
hyperinflation where people have just
lost their money to inflation relatively
few people have access to the banking
system it's a it's a you know takes
weeks to open a basic bank account so
here comes Bitcoin and they're ordinary
people who are already used to kind of
working around the edges of the
financial system and here's something
that allows them to hold their own money
if they want to buy something online
they don't need a credit card they can
order it immediately and so these are
folks who are generally not motivated by
the politics of Bitcoin but they're
using it in a way that's very much in
keeping with the original politics of
Bitcoin and and again as I said it's
really one of the only places where I
think ordinary people are using Bitcoin
for everyday transactions with that then
they're not I mean one of the things
that's weird about Bitcoin and this is
also true of PayPal and even credit
cards which allow more fluidity are they
taking are at any point are they you
know swapping Bitcoin for actual fiat
currency or are they in Argentina are
they staying more with
in the Bitcoin economy both are
happening there's a lot of movement in
and out and what's interesting and
what's facilitated this there is that
there are Bitcoin brokers you know
ordinary people who will go go to your
house and change your Bitcoin into pesos
or dollars or whatever you want for you
and that negates the need for for a bank
account in the United States a lot of
people who buy and sell Bitcoin do it
from a bank account they send money from
their bank account to a Bitcoin exchange
back and forth but of course their their
money is again tied up in a financial
institution and Argentina they remain
outside the financial ins system by
using these brokers who allow them to
move in and out of digital cash and
physical cash Ross Ulbricht creator of
the online drug market Silk Road which
also sold and bought and sold a lot of
other things but he's a major character
in your book and in a lot of ways Silk
Road is the demonstration model of you
know that okay you know this stuff works
and you know in all sorts of ways and
people will rely on it to transfer
things to it in very anonymous
circumstances since the book went to
press ohlbrecht has gotten a life
sentence and you know that's a
punishment that was widely decried as as
unfair you do in your book detail to
cases where Ulbricht or he was charged
with or actually was not charged with
but he was kind of accused of
facilitating murders for hire what can
you tell us a little bit about that and
how do you feel about Albrecht and his
treatment in the courts I mean I think
that the the documents have laid out
pretty clearly from Ross's own computer
that in his final year of running the
Silk Road he did sort of work with
people on the Silk Road to try to
basically off some some folks who were
trying to screw him that were trying to
screw other customers and he felt that
in order to save the Silk Road he needed
to essentially kill these people in both
cases it appears that he was actually
being duped and those people may have
been agent provocateurs who were trying
to get him to do this
and nobody it appears was actually
killed as you say the government did not
bring those instances up in court and
and there are a lot of sort of
complicated strange reasons for that and
in the end what Ross went to prison for
was essentially sort of running this
narcotics Empire do you have a sense
that you know it on a much more profound
and serious level that Silk Road is kind
of like Napster where you know now music
everybody uses streaming music services
and they're legitimate and that the big
corporations and the small players all
use it do you think you know something
like Silk Road a bit coin operated
anonymous marketplace you know that's
going to be the future even as you know
we forget about Ross Ulbricht that's a
great question I think the comparison
with Napster and Bitcoin and Silk Road
is interesting on all kinds of levels
you know is this going to be like
Napster which gets supplanted just by
iTunes just by another sort of corporate
giant or is it actually going to allow
for you know a greater decentralization
of commerce and I think one of the most
interesting projects on that level is
something called open Bazaar which was
initially created after the Silk Road
went down to serve as a sort of
replacement a decentralized replacement
where you wouldn't have somebody like
Ross Ulbricht at the center that
everything relied on and what's
fascinating with with open Bazaar is
that it's kind of again evolved from its
hacker roots and has recently gotten
funding from andreessen horowitz and
Union Square Ventures and you know very
serious venture capitalists who are
betting on some sort of decentralization
of commerce and whether that includes
drug sales I think is an open question
you know at some point once you have a
decentralized platform for buying and
selling things the the owners of it or
whoever built it doesn't necessarily
have a choice in whether drugs are sold
pellet it's also interesting that
Bitcoin in its early kind of appearances
in the press oftentimes it's talked
about it's the ultimate anonymous way to
transact things but in fact it kind of
because there's that universal ledger
you can yak purchases
excruciating detail yeah I mean it's the
both most anonymous for money and the
most unknown amiss form of money I mean
in some ways a lot of the uses that
banks are talking about is actually as a
way to create a sort of universal
digital identity you know where you can
be tracked everywhere and through each
of your accounts and you know the idea
behind Bitcoin is that you just have an
address that's a mixture of letters and
numbers but as soon as your name is
attached to that address
everybody knows all your transactions
yes missus I mean it this goes back to
early enlightenment theorists you know
where some of them were like ultimate
transparency of knowing everything and
how everything works perfectly that's
incredibly empowering and other people
saying that's totalitarian in it you
can't escape so it's a weird phase you
know after tumbling from over 1,000
being worth one thousand US dollars
Bitcoin dropped its prices rising again
there's an entire industry that's
growing up around Bitcoin in other forms
of cryptocurrency
do you I mean do you feel like Bitcoin
or the net Bitcoin as a model is here to
stay you know I've heard from too many
smart people in in what on Wall Street
and in Silicon Valley that they think it
is inevitable that this is going to play
a role in what comes next in you know
the the maintenance of information on
the internet I mean I'm a skeptic at
heart and so I see the ways in which
Bitcoin has failed and I wonder if
that's that's those those issues are
eventually going to imperil it but I
just see so many people who are working
on and and in some ways the fact that it
survived through those first seven years
you have to imagine that those are the
first the toughest seven years certainly
the first two years were the toughest
when it wasn't worth anything what are
what are some of the ways that it's
failed so far certainly the the
anonymity that people anticipated has
been less complete than they hoped for I
think that the security that people have
hoped for
yes it there's a private key that'll
gives you access to your bitcoins and
that system is very secure but but what
about the private key it's very
hard to keep that private key securely
and so that's been a real vulnerability
that if somebody has your private key
they essentially have your bitcoins and
there have been a number of high-profile
both collapses of entire exchanges but
also heists right I mean over the
weekend it's it's like a science fiction
novel where you read like oh there's
Bitcoin repositories being drained over
the weekend by hackers right I mean the
amount of money that's been lost is sort
of staggering and the fact that it
survived those losses is sort of amazing
you know in your book a lot of the
characters have these kind of aha
moments where they're like oh you know
yes this is what I'm all about or I'm
going big on Bitcoin as a technology or
as a speculative currency or whatever
and you know where they really get into
it did you know did you you put your
life on hold to write this book did you
have an aha moment about Bitcoin and
what was the revelation to you well to
me as a journalist the thing that's so
fascinating is is the people and their
stories and and for me I was covering
this for about a year before I decided
it was worth writing a book about and
part of that was hearing the number of
people who were taking it serious
serious people taking seriously but the
other and perhaps more important part
was just meeting people who had kind of
thrown their lives away to chase this
dream and there was something in that
you don't see very often that I needed
to understand and to me that was the
understanding that that that sort of
made me throw myself into this and
figure out what was it about this idea
that kind of made people so excited
passionate crazy those were some of
those people who didn't end up having
the greatest impact on blood coin but
that you know this is in a sense of
social movement getting people excited
it's not getting people to use this
thing could you talk a little bit about
I mean does Bitcoin in in this push
towards decentralization in this kind of
marriage of a social movement to a
certain degree in ideological movement
and a technological movement is this
part of kind of the great opening up of
over maybe the past 20 30 40 years of
kind of computer to enable technological
possibilities yes I mean look III think
that I certainly see how this could play
out in the way that the internet did and
sort of slowly applications allowing it
to disintermediate different industries
you know was it was media and commerce
and and communication and you know
Finance hasn't really been
disintermediating you have this small
number of companies that are sort of
involved in all the financial
transactions and I think that's what
bitcoin holds out the promise of doing
now I think at the same time you have to
deal with the same questions that the
internet has dealt with which is does it
really decentralize things or does it
just allow kind of breaking up of old
powers and then a creation of a bunch of
new centralized powers so it's let's say
IBM takes it on the chin but now we have
Apple so that it's not it's not a bold
new model it's just allowing new players
right and and you know in the Napster
example you had the record labels and
they have been largely disempowered but
you know now you've got iTunes and
Spotify and the question is how
different is that what what are the
benefits that we got and moving from one
to the other
okay well we'll leave it there we've
been talking with Nathaniel popper he is
the author of the great new book digital
gold Bitcoin and the inside story of the
misfits and millionaires trying to
reinvent money thank you for reason TV
I'm Nicolas
you